okay how many people here have
experience with a
tests with let's say stuff like Jasmine
what else is there mocha chai jest I'm
gonna use just today just so you know
just so you know
you can expect more of that humor for
the next 50 minutes yes
paid for this stuff okay uh so there's
unit testing and there's test-driven
development how many people here have
tried test-driven development like
literally writing the test before they
code how many people are actively doing
it at work yeah that's what I thought
okay can we start the guy beyond I don't
know what you want to do okay sir we got
rid of Twitter that's good
so hello everybody my name is Roy
hush Rove I am the author of art of unit
testing I wrote it a long time ago and
then a second version came out and
everyone keeps asking still asking the
same questions like how do we start
doing unit testing etc and I realized
that you can't just write a book and
then expect the world to change so I
start you know leaving
working as a manager as the director
start learning about how do we motivate
people how do we change behaviors Nesta
book called elastic leadership and I'm
currently working on two books the third
edition of art of unit testing which is
going to be written in JavaScript
instead of in c-sharp because I thought
what the hell I gotta I gotta learn
JavaScript and what is the best way to
learn JavaScript then to prove to the
world that you have no idea about
JavaScript by writing a book about it
and that would force me into kind of a
pressure and I love it I've learned so
much about you know I used to play with
JavaScript all the time but really
getting into it and functional style
versus object-oriented style and higher
order functions a lot of that kind of
geeky stuff it's so interesting and I
was wondering whether the same patterns
from the original book with the hold in
the JavaScript world the good news is
that about 80% of them are still true in
the JavaScript world they just the
implementation details are a bit
different and I'm also writing a book
called pipeline driven which is all
about Auto continuous delivery at
enterprise scale but that's
talk of us for us today um so today
we're gonna you know understand
understand test-driven development okay
there's a difference between just
showing it versus understanding it thank
you
versus understanding white matters why
does it actually make a difference
because we can all know the three
different rules right the red the green
refactor it takes five minutes to
understand that concept what's the point
of each one what does it feel like in
real life so we're gonna use a short
demo or a password verifier which is a
small kata that I like to do I used to
have a kata called string calculator
which I still like but I find that in
the JavaScript world the password
verifier feels about feels nicer so I'll
show the beginning of that and then
we'll touch on two common questions the
first common question is what is TDD
because there are various meanings of it
and I think that's also where a lot of
the confusion but a lot of the
misunderstandings and sometimes
confrontations happen around the
development world so let me talk to you
about the FIR the four different ways
that people see TDD when I talk to them
some people just say ott do that test
test first you just write the test first
and that's just the way it is you just
that's how we treat it it's a very
simple kind of practice some people just
say oh we're test driven but they just
mean they're test oriented they have a
lot of tests if your organization if
someone your organization says oh we're
definitely test driven we're doing TDD
but they just mean they write a lot of
tests after the code a lot of people
still refer to that as test-driven
development some people view TDD as a
test driven design wherein you would let
the TDD process dictate the entire
design of of your system so basically
you could start with almost zero design
and TDD will kind of guide you and I
think a great example of that is in the
book growing object-oriented software
guided by tests the Goose book so that
book is is perfect if you will learn
that type of philosophy I'm kind of
somewhere in the middle I I say to me to
my two mice
off that TPD is about developing new
features and also getting guidance on
design but it doesn't mean that I start
with no design it means that I do have
some design notions I might go into a
session with a whiteboard or even a
document or a few diagrams and I'll
start working but as I progress I might
realize a lot of design mistakes and I
might change my design based on my tests
so he said i I would say it's more of a
pragmatic nature
I definitely don't try to be a purist
about it I try to be very very pragmatic
so that's the person we're going to take
today
if you want understand where TD came
from where where I first heard about it
is in a book called extreme programming
explained and in that book the idea of
test-driven development came up as one
of the practices in extreme programming
or XP today I would say extreme
programming shouldn't be named extreme
programming it should just be named
programming because XP is to me with the
thing that makes successful agile teams
it is the underlying core practices that
teams today are learning the hard way
that they should have been doing all
along to actually succeed in working in
small iteration incremental development
so we may not call it that but slowly
and surely the the the industry is
adopting these practices one by Mandor
like smuggling XP into safe and I don't
all of these huge waterfall based stuff
we're we're kind of sneaking things into
them and then there was a great book by
Kent Beck called test-driven development
by example has anyone read that book by
the way still hold true I still like it
and that's where I learned about it and
I and then I went to my first team as a
team lead and I said we are going to do
TDD and of course we had many many many
mistakes we we made a lot of mistakes in
our test our tests were not maintainable
they were not readable they cost us a
bunch and we actually had to delete a
few well a few percent a few tens of
percentages of the tests at some point
during the project because when we were
working on the text on the tests we
created glue toward the design of our
application where we couldn't basically
change things so there is this whole
notion of three different skills in TDD
that's the way I see it there are three
different skills the first skill is
writing good tests okay and that has
nothing to do with writing them first
you can write really crappy tests first
and I've seen many people do that I can
also write really good tests after the
code has been written so this
maintainability readability and Trust or
three core principles of good tests and
then there's the skill of writing the
tests first which is a separate skill
altogether and we can learn it
separately we can written practice it
separately
the final skill is design the design is
the thing that I think is the hardest to
learn and we have to practice it slowly
throughout our development lifetime tpd
helps understand that there might be
design issues but it does not solve your
design skills I've seen plenty of people
with less knowledge about design create
bad architectures or hard to maintain or
very very hard very fragile
architectures and basically blaming the
way that they work on the tests
requirements but I I feel like every
problem can be solved in many different
ways in terms of design and that's one
of the things that we have to learn is
that these three different skills are
the reason why a lot of people don't do
TDD because they start and then they
face this huge wall they have to learn
how to write the test first they have to
learn how to write good tests and they
have to learn about design in a way that
they may have not considered before
that's a big challenge to get into ok
so let's just get into it very very
quickly TDD the three main steps we've
all seen it before right to make it fail
make it pass refactor red green refactor
I'm created this kind of short diagram
to explain what it really looks like in
real life to me when I work in T in a
TDD fashion I usually start with the
simplest test that proves that something
is wrong ok I try to work very very
incrementally so I write a test to prove
the next small piece of functionality is
missing could be that the feature is
returning the wrong value it could be
the feature can't cannot even be
callable maybe the code doesn't even
exist yet I just prove it I think of it
like a bug
and as soon as I write the test and I
get the test to be runnable that is
maybe some code has to exist for the
test to even execute it but still fail I
should run all the tests because I want
to write the test but I don't want to
have any functionality added except the
most basic stuff to get the transpilers
working etc so all my tests should fail
at this point or at least the first test
and then the next step is to get my the
test that I just wrote to pass without
changing the test okay so I I basically
describe this vision of in a perfect
world I should be able to write a test
like this and it should pass obviously
the test fails so then I make it that
world that I wish I had by making the
test pass in the simplest way possible
simple we'll talk about the reasoning
for that the next step is to refactor
once this once all the tests are passing
I'll incrementally refactor my code I'll
do as one small refactor and then I'll
run all the tests to make sure I didn't
break anything and then maybe I'll
repeat that I'll do a few small
refactorings and for each one of them
I'll continue running the test for each
one of them and I kind of repeat this
process until I like the code okay and
then I repeat and I move over the next
functionality so there are two main
loops in TDD the way I see them today
you have the the initial loop which is
all about making the code that you trust
so you know the code is actually working
and then at the lower loop is code that
you like so if you don't do the
refactoring step what you end up is code
that you trust
but you hate okay you're gonna get ugly
code that works which is still better
than 55 percent of companies out there
unfortunately that I've seen they have
ugly code and they're not even sure that
it works so at least this way we can
refactor if we have the tests but the
refactoring part this is where you know
these two skills is this this skill of
adding the code that you trust this is
to me development TDD to me is about
driving new functionality and it's fast
if I if I don't
explain it to people if I just work with
someone or I work alone he is a very
very fast process you'll see in the demo
that it can be fast even when we explain
things but in there I have two missions
how did I trust and code that I liked
and the design skill happens in these
locations far as I can see we design or
we understand the design that we'd like
to have when we first write the test
when I just write the test and the code
doesn't even exist yet that's where I
test my initial assumption of what the
design should look like right what are
the parameters of the function do I like
the naming whatever and I can change
things there with basically zero cost
because the code doesn't exist yet if I
start from scratch and then I start
using it and during the refactoring I
might refine my design
okay so that the code is more
maintainable and readable so the design
at the top is the function functional
design that is how do we input stuff
into the application how we do we change
the state of the application how do we
get back some results right what is the
path of least resistance for our test to
actually invoke and this design here is
about kind of making the thing that's
already working making it something we
can be proud of and that design could be
extracting new interfaces it could be
extracting functions into smaller
functions
it could be separating two different
files because by the time we get to this
lower level we have code that works but
it might be pretty ugly so that thing is
kind of continuous refactoring that'll
think about so if we want to practice
the devika TDD I would recommend TDD
Coty's has anyone here practiced one of
these cutters before or some other for
those of you that don't know what a kata
is it's taken from the martial arts
world and I think the reason we're using
the word kata is because as developers
we all want to feel cool and so we just
want to say we're like the ninja of the
and whatever so it's kind of lame but
it's kind of nice too
so let's embrace our geeky and lame
behavior and say we're doing TDD Coty's
so the nice thing about kata is if we
can kind of embrace this idea is that in
a kata you repeat the same thing
multiple times and each time you kind of
optimize you change small things on the
way you get to use you get muscle memory
on how to do things the beginning you do
them slower and you get faster and
faster you get used to them being almost
second nature and to me that's one of
the best ways to practice TDD because at
work what we usually do is we solve
different problems all the time in cut
as you solve the same problem
continuously multiple times and you look
at the way that you solve it as an
optimization technique so we can use
cutters to learn specific practices we
can even use Coty's to learn new
programming languages when I switched
from c-sharp to Ruby for example I did a
bunch of Coty's for learning Ruby which
are basically a bunch of failing tests
and you had to get them passing by
getting actual code to run but because I
know how tests work and the tests were
very very small and functional to test
one specific feature of the language it
was a beautiful way to learn so every
time I learned a lesson a test has had
become green it was a wonderful feeling
so if you you're looking for learning
new languages look for TDD Cowen's KOA N
and there's a bunch of them for
different languages the one we're gonna
use is password verify ur let's just
kind of jump into a demo the this demo
just to show the way TDD works is going
to be about password verification and I
find password certification nice because
in terms of design there are many ways
to solve this and I start with this kind
of initial requirement for a design it's
might change later on but I do note that
I want something that kind of looks like
this I want a verify pass function it
takes an input which is a string which
is the password to verify and the set of
rules and the rules at this point
they're just a bunch of rules and if one
of them is returning false then
basically our password should fail and
this verify pass is returning true or
false so it's it's it looks like it's a
very very simple kind of thing but we
can make it more and more complicated as
the requirements grow
we just switch to this so my editor of
choice here is IntelliJ I know that many
people here see this and say why isn't
he using vyas code or whatever um ah I
like them both you know as a friend
but I find sometimes the refactorings
IntelliJ are kind of a bit a bit more
powerful
okay so the first thing we want to do
the first thing we want to realize when
we're talking about TDD remember the the
first steps right make it fail make it
pass refactor if we're starting new code
in TDD this is kind of what we're
staring at I want to write this verifier
and now what it's like like an author
looking at the blank page like okay I
don't know what to do if I was doing
this traditionally my initial thought is
okay just just declare a function write
declare a function called verify pass
and then add some tests to it that's
kind of the let's call it the classic
traditional way but in a TDD way I
wouldn't even touch this this file first
I would actually go to the spec file and
create a spec file and I'll write the
test before I even write any code here
so if you think about is the first rule
is you don't write extra functionality
in the code without a failing test
basically our production code is read
only until we have a failing test
production code by the way does anyone
know what is the definition of
production code in our dem in our little
demo what is production code it's any
code that's not tests okay
production code is any code that is not
tests its code that eventually will make
it to production so if I want to start
working on verifier my first instinct is
to open the spec file so I mean oh I
created an empty spec file especially
for this group of fine people and the
first thing I want to do is of course
anyone tell me
I had a testing okay which test will be
right let's start if I'm not even sure
I'm not even gonna do requires or
anything by the way I'm not using
typescript for this demo I'm using pure
vanilla yes what is it
yes 2015 because I find it just creates
extra noise with all the transpilers etc
but you can take it to whatever platform
you're working on so the first thing I
do is I alright as quick describe block
let me make this a bit bigger
readable
so the first is the first describe block
is the thing is usually describing the
name of a feature or the name of an
entry point somewhere in the code that I
would like the test now in this case the
feature seems pretty simple it's verify
pass that is the entry point and an
entry point in my tests is the thing
where the execution begins because when
we're talking about unit testing we're
talking about defining a unit of work
and a unit of work has an entry point it
has exit points and the entry point is
where our test invokes it for the first
time and the path of execution begins
but the exit point could either be by a
return value it could also be an exit
point where we changed the state of the
system so maybe the function doesn't
even return anything and it could be a
third party like sending stuff to a log
file or sending emails or whatever
in fact one function can have multiple
exit points okay but in our case we have
to describe where the entry point is so
it could be the name of a function it
could be the name of a feature I still
like to use the name of a function even
though sometimes because the function is
public that it's less likely to change
names but if if if that happens then
worst case NRL changed one described so
verify
ass now I'm using just and ingest you
can you can have either it or test it
doesn't matter I used to be in a very
and in simple camp that would say don't
just do describe do a nested describe
like this that says okay for verify pass
I will do a describe for a scenario
which is okay what is the first scenario
would like to test let's say no rules
because that's a simple scenario can
think of but we can test this verify
pass with multiple different scenarios I
would say no rules right and then here I
might have an eight or a test which
would end up with kind of three pieces
of information the entry point the
scenario and the expected behavior and I
find that these three pieces of
information are the things that I'm
looking for when I'm trying to
understand the test without looking at
the code for the test so making the test
names readable is a core part of making
our code maintainable because we can't
understand can't maintain it but for
simple tests I won't even do this I'll
just do like a simple test like this and
I'll put a couple of information points
here for example with no rules and I'll
put a comma here I know some people are
not crazy about that no rules it what
should it do
it passes right yeah passes okay so this
is at the beginning this is where I I'm
thinking about different scenarios I
haven't thought about design yet I just
have to actually start writing something
so what if we do this Const result
equals verify pass notice I'm just using
the function as if it already exists
I haven't required it yet etc and I'll
explain why in a second
now what value should I send to it as
the input password any ideas
all right empty string what else
sorry
you are a real Task Force
Oh my real password
okay
another one of dad jokes this one what
happens when you have three kids okay my
real password nice to me okay whatever
so here's the thing you were all wrong
so what we'll do is we want to give an
input that forces the reader of our
tests to not ask any questions they'll
just understand and one of the things
the important things about test is to
explain to the reader what is not
important now what is important is that
there are no rules if there are no rules
it doesn't matter what the input is do
we agree on that so I'll just write any
input in fact when you write tests I
highly encourage it to imagine that the
person who's gonna read your tests is a
serial killer that knows where you live
okay you do not want them to ask
unnecessary questions and if I put here
let's say 42 which some of you might
want to tell me at some point then not
everyone has read that book in fact some
people in this audience already are like
42 that looks like a nice number but why
what's so important about 42 in fact
let's do it 37
why 37 nobody knows nobody will ever
know the person who wrote this test left
the company a year ago 37 must be
important what happens when we think
something is important we duplicated in
our own tests so suddenly you see 37 in
hundreds of tests across the universe
why 37 well the elders have told me this
is the magic number required to make the
right inputs into the application you
find the elder they like now I was drunk
what do you want from me no so we do not
want magic inputs we just say any input
and an empty set of rules
are so good I did I did I forget
something something is wrong here right
oh I'm missing the function and then
we'll just do an expect result result
result to be
be
truthy I hate this name to be truthful
but it is kind of a JavaScript thing I
guess are we missing something
I do have a spare parenthesis right in
line seven
delete now by the way
just want to tell you this guy he knows
he understands the pair programming he
just goes dude line seven right is what
are we gonna do am i gonna actually read
my own code the code that I wrote no so
it's already legacy code as I write it
okay verify pass okay so now this is the
this is the fun part do I like this
design or not because some of you are
looking at this and you have some
experience of JavaScript me you're like
no I would never write verify pass like
this I'd write something like a
higher-order function that is like Const
verify verify pass equals make very fire
that takes the empty set of rules and
then here
like this so I would configure the rules
before I get the function and the
function already has rules okay now
notice that I just changed the design of
my application and there was zero cost
because the code doesn't exist yet it's
so much fun now I get to try it I get to
see you I like this joint like this kind
of pattern is it readable to me do I do
I want to change it in some other way
maybe I need extra parameters and as
soon as I like the test that's when I
committed to kind of to actual existence
by actually making it pass so for the
purposes of this demo I'm gonna keep it
very very simple but in your own
personal lives and your own personal
passions of higher-order functions and
whatever you want to do go crazy as long
as you write the test first with that
design and decide that you like it so if
I like this I can just go ahead and say
Const verify as equals require what what
was it verified yes okay
and then I would go to verify Jas and
make this S Pen ow I'm gonna use for the
test runner I'm just gonna use wallaby I
think it's a very nice test runner but
you can also use jest and with the watch
parameters I like wallaby because it
shows me very very quickly errors in my
code and and coverage etc and I can
already see there's a type error or
fight pass is not a function which
totally makes sense because verifier
doesn't exist yet let me just put this
here on the right and write this
verifier module exports verify pass
good and you can see already that I'm
getting kind of this line was working
this line was working this line major
issue I can see the error right here so
I get very very fast feedback which when
I'm working on TDD you know should I
make the font bigger when I'm working on
TDD it's definitely something I want I
want very very quick feedback because I
want to move fast okay so what else
Const a verify
Murphy verify pass so difficult to type
thing this in front of people okay
verify pass equals what we have an input
and rules right
yes I know you're missing typescript at
this point but doesn't matter equals
this one you know what we can actually
just return like false
okay so what happened here I returned
false because I wanted to feel like a
bug right I want the test run and I want
the test to fail and I wanted to feel
like a bug and that's kind of the first
rule of TDD I want the first when I
write a test I want to see it fail
before I see it to pass what's the
reason for this I mean technically I
could just just sent in and actually
parse stuff and do whatever I needed any
what's the reason for this
okay proof that the test has value
proving that the test is actually good
and that's one of the things that I like
about TDD is that in TDD I actually test
the test right as if I wrote the test
after in it passed how would I know that
it would fail when it needs to an entity
I get to see it fail when it needs to
and then without touching the test it
should magically pass when I get the
production code to a specific situation
so I test my test and that brings me
Trust if I don't trust my tests what
happens let's say that my test passed
and I don't trust them my next
inclination is to debug the code anyway
just to make sure to manually test stuff
what happens if my tests fail and I
don't trust them then you hear the
dreaded sentence don't worry about it
okay it only fails every third time on
the first moon of the and only if you're
in like Swedish whatever
okay so we don't trust the test and
suddenly when a test actually fails for
a real bug we don't trust it and we fail
to see so I want my tests when they fail
in unit test when they fail I want to
actually feel frightened annoyed not
frightened but you know what kind of
worried something's read I feel like I
should do something about it so that's
the first reason that I like to do TDD
is that I test my test so now I get to
go to the second stage which is getting
all my tests to pass in the simplest way
possible right would be very naive way
but it still has to change the
functionality in some way so what is the
simplest way to change my production
code and getting all the tests to pass
no speakers allowed
true okay what's your name sir
it is okay so you eat this is said make
it true
so my question to you this is is this
how you write code in your company
we're all screwed if this is what
happens just to make you happy
I'm going to make it true
now you can see that everything turns
green and in my head right I'm gonna
like Oh obviously I've done amazing job
here and this is where TDD fails us so
yet again look look what you made me do
ROI is this a code that I can be proud
of
no can I react to this oh I can return a
class that returns an object that
returns true no okay so this sucks
we all agreed this sucks thanks you this
ever
this is it sucks I can't it's the first
rule of TDD states you can't change
functionality without a failing test if
I want to say if I want to change this
because it sucks I can't I have to write
a new test that fails that proves that
it sucks okay so now I've first forced
myself to write a new test it says ah
not so fast buddy true is not good
enough but let's do that okay so think
of it like right brain and left brain so
now I have to write a test that proves
that my code sucks so what is the
simplest test to prove that this code
sucks any ideas
NORs fails
okay so tell me so tell me in the real
world would you have two tests passing
where one of them is no rules passes and
no rules fails enough frankly we will
find that type of code in the real world
I don't know parallelism whatever so
what is a test that should be true in
the real world while the first test is
still true as well write the simplest
test right if I said look no rules it
passes and I'm like yeah sure that means
it always passes right then what do I
have to prove I have to prove that no no
sometimes it doesn't pass so what's the
best way to prove it come on anyone give
me an idea
okay we definitely have to send a rule
okay so let's do that so we definitely
need a rule here let's do that should be
a failing or a passing rule it is what
Bailey are you sure
two points just for being so brave I
appreciate you as a friend
so one failed rule
happen come on not eat us
come on people
purse okay very
I passed any input now obviously here
now we have sent an empty amount right
and here we want to send and
single rule so in this case a rule can
be you know we get an input and we just
return false there's there's there's no
other reason to send it and of course
this has to be to be all see another
amazing name developed okay um let's
make this font a bit bigger smaller a
bit bigger
okay so now we can see this test is
failing I can see the error here I can
go to production I can see that it's
failing
I can see receive true when it was
actually expected to be false so now I
can go ahead and say you know what okay
I can't just Coast and just and because
I can't be the laziest developer in the
world and still get all the tests
passing I actually have to do something
so you know what we can do something
like this if rules length and of course
you have your own implementation in your
head right equals a 0 return true
otherwise
all right
wait I did what's your name
is your name will I regret that
gonna be okay I will never embarrass you
anymore than I embarrassed myself so yes
you might regret it
well now I'm just kidding you get two
points because you have given me the
right answer because in my brain there
are two halves now there is the laziest
developer lay his developer in the world
that just wants to go home get all the
tests passing and then there's the the
strict developers like uh-huh
you missed a spot okay so I'm the
laziest developer return false Jesus
that's crappy code unfortunately all the
tests are passing right so now the
annoying developer gets to say no come
on we all know that what you really want
to do is I mean this code sucks right so
let me just prove it to you so how would
I prove it let's see we had one failed
rule fails we have so what if we had
what come on
yes one rule that passes one a single
rule passes so notice I'm like no not
good enough yeah not good enough to be
truthy okay and of course this fails and
I get to go here and say okay how do I
make all the tests pass now in the
simplest ways possible
any ideas
sorry I cannot touch the test I have to
get that all the tests passing without
touching the tests
input true
well again I don't want to cheat I
wanted to actually work so without
cheating on the test
sorry
line 18 here yeah so what you're saying
is that it should be returning
yeah it should be a passing rule
wait hold on oh this is an interesting
situation let's keep the bug in the test
okay screw all of you I think I'm right
Nana hold on not yet
found a bug in my tests I don't have bug
in my tests you have bug in your tests
okay so I'll prove to you okay here here
it's very simple rules zero sorry the
first rule
just going to call it with input
there you go holy [ __ ] you were right
okay so one good reason to do TDD is
because I want to test my test right and
I just tested my test and my test failed
the logic in my test failed right cuz
this should have passed my test should
have done this right so now it's green
again but I'm just gonna go okay return
false again because I want to see that
my test fails again because now I know
my test is correct and then I'm just
gonna okay that that worked let's do it
let's let's repeat back and now I got to
see my test failing and passing and I
even found a bug in my tests okay so
pair programming saved me but who
actually does pair programming come on
okay I mean I I do it but most people
don't so they won't find the bug in
their test but this is a good way to
find a bugs in your test okay so now we
all agree that this code still sucks
right but now it sucks a little less
than previously in fact I could say if I
had to commit now and push this stuff
into production I have a incrementally
working piece of code I support zero
rules and I support a single rule I
don't support multiple rules yet but
technically my code works more than it
did before it's not a one or zero result
so one of the benefits that I find in
TDD is that we can very easily create
incremental development micro iterations
if you will and if my code is always at
this kind of ready state there is always
a passing test but there's always only
one failing test away from passing and I
can get it passing then every few
minutes I have a shippable piece of code
that I can put in like a feature flag or
whatever I want so far so good
let's see now I can go ahead and say we
have we can have multiple rules and I
can write a new test for that but how
much time how much more time do we have
left
let's say ten and a half minutes so
we're gonna jump in because I want to
talk about a few important questions
that that I had for you
[Music]
okay so some common questions that
people ask when I when I hop sorry
is better okay so why do we write it
okay just for you guys
why do we write the test before we write
the code
come on why do we write the test before
we write the code
the seat fail now that's why do white
that's a different question why do we
even write the test before the coat
to have tests that's a good answer so
here's my answer because otherwise
you'll never have time to write them
okay if you
before the code you always have time to
write tests isn't life beautiful
because you don't actually have to ask
permission to write tests you know that
right
so the people in the camera you know
that right you don't have to ask
permission to write tests just like you
don't get permission to debug your code
you don't need permission to write test
for your code if you start with the
tests you get all of these benefits geez
sorry I'm sorry yeah yeah you think
through the requirements and you think
about the design remember that design
feeling that we had before and we get
all that stuff working okay so my next
my next question is why do we make it
fail first you wanted to take a picture
right but if I open the screen your
camera will burn so why do we make the
test fail first now is a good time to
answer
a
sorry
to test the test that's right it's test
test-driven development
okay so when the test passes we're done
okay okay next question
remember we solve things as simple okay
I just have to take a picture she's
actually putting on sunglasses that's
awesome
two points okay so why do we solve it as
simply as possible
remember that our arm sorry that our
design has changed and our design has
forced us to kind of change add
functionality but also add tests
refactoring we haven't done a lot of
refactoring because we didn't get to
that point but probably in the next test
I would start doing a bunch of reef
actors work incrementally you know we
talked about incremental work okay
here's an another question that someone
asked me why not just write like 20
tests failing and then solve them one by
one I mean technically that could work
and as someone who is done that myself I
will tell you that it does work but it
creates a whole set new set of problems
because let's say you have 20 failing
tests and you won't want to make them
all pass by not touching them our
initial human psychology forces us to
try to do the smartest thing we can
possibly do in production code and try
to get as many of them passing at the
same time which basically creates much
more complicated code than we need to
and also creates code that has more
features than we're actually testing
usually by doing it one by one I'm
forcing myself into a very very small
narrow loop that forces me to work on
one piece of functionality at a time in
a very incremental way without
complicating my design more than I need
to
and the refactoring step will make my
design better okay so this is a this is
a an experiment that I did at a company
a few good years ago and in the company
I was passed with working with a bunch
of development groups on test-driven
development
and this company was basically adopting
or adapting features to customers of the
same kind of infrastructure and they got
to work on two different customers with
the same adaptation the same requirement
for a feature so I we actually had an
agreement with the managers to kind of
keep metrics on these two different
groups because one of them had went
through my-my-my we were consulting for
them and we were training them they had
about three months experience with the
TDD so they weren't kind of very very
fast but we wanted kind of to measure
and so we have were lucky to work on the
same type of feature for two different
customers with two different teams one
team was not doing TDD they were not
really doing unit testing too much they
were mostly doing either manual testing
or integration testing or combination of
those two and of course there were there
was also a QA team so what we can see
first is that the first line is that the
implementation of the code for the team
working in TDD was double the amount of
time and it makes sense because when you
work in a test-driven fashion your code
you're 60% of your code can end up being
tests because for every line of code
there is a test that proves that that
line is supposed to be there usually
right so the implementation took double
the amount of time and then there was
this kind of a this was a waterfall
company this would they went through the
entire you know bug fix and review and
change and whatever and they ended up
kind of releasing after 22 days so just
three days after the other team was
releasing their feature so now the
question was they ended up instead of
seven days they kind of removed four
days from those seven through the bug
fixing in the testing they found less
bugs when they did find bugs the tests
were helping them to find where the bugs
are or to recreate a new bug to recreate
the bugs and actually solve them so then
the question is okay if it took three
days more what did we get for the three
days so here's what we found out
the amount of production bugs for the
other team on the right was 90% less
than yet then the team on the left okay
they then we had surveys we were asking
teams about confidence and design and
API and and basically we got much
happier teams and also happier customers
as we got less bugs now when I when I
showed this slide in classes when I
teach usually people say no you're
missing an important part in this
process which is absolutely true so I
removed one part of that process in that
company and that is the integration part
okay so in that company they had what we
call integration or our or hell week
okay so because there are many other
teams they had to integrate with there
was a lot of code so usually before you
release a feature into in the customers
there was a hell week for integration
testing you you know you work very very
late hours coffee spilled on the floor
all that good stuff a lot of fun so
there was still bugs found for
integration for the team was on the
right but much less okay they still had
integration bugs but a lot of the time
they actually found that they can either
recreate the bugs or they would stop
debugging in the logic code and go
directly to configuration because the
unit tests for the same functionality
were passing so eventually what actually
happened is that the team on the right
released two days earlier than the team
on the left
even though implementation the coding
right in a waterfall organization took
double the amount of time the bottom
line is they actually released faster
because the feedback loops were faster
the fixes were faster when they had
regressions they could find them faster
and they would fix them as they happened
instead of through a manual verification
process so to me what what's scary about
TDD is that it's very easy to see the
first line and it's very difficult to
see the bottom line because the bottom
line usually you won't get to this
situation where you get to compare
you'll find the bottom line after a few
good months of work if not more at your
company and by then is gonna be very
difficult to get everyone kind of into
that zone because as a manager if I see
double the amount of time feel scary it
makes sense so we have to realize that
that time
invested at the top is returned to us in
the middle so it gets reduced but it's
very hard to measure that time in a
normal day-to-day work if you want to
find out more resources about TD DS and
to look at the cauda if you want to get
the first three chapters of the upcoming
art of unit testing book go to this link
and fill out the form and I'll promise
that I'll send you a download of a PDF
or those first three chapters with a
promise to send you future emails about
when the book actually arrives in full
you can find the you know more stuff
about me and stuff that I teach I'm
actually teaching a workshop tomorrow on
TDD in JavaScript for the full day so
I'd love to see you there if you want to
join me and you can find out more about
the book and tweet me on Twitter thank
you very much everybody
I appreciate you may the force be with
you
[Applause]